[S01] 时至此刻，呃，你可能正期待着手机上的应用能在几毫秒内做出反应，对吧？
[S02] 嗯，现在的用户早就习惯了这种及时满足感。
[S01] 没错，就是你点开一个网页或者发一条信息，一切都必须是及时、低延迟的。但你可能没有意识到，呃，那个能跟你对答如流的AI助手，还有每年年底让你惊呼太懂我了的年度听歌报告。
[S02] 还有屏幕上那些极其精准的商品推荐。
[S01] 对对对，这些体验的背后，其实其实是有一头行动缓慢、古老而又隐形的巨手在默默支撑着。
[S02] 欢迎加入我们本次的深度解析。
[S01] 很高兴能在这个时间和你一起探讨。
[S02] 嗯，今天我们要拆解的核心呢是一份极其扎实的硬核技术资料，就是《设计数据密集型应用》，也就是大家常说的 DDIA 的第十一章。
[S01] 这本书在业界确实是神作级别的。
[S02] 绝对的。我们今天的任务就是帮你把这本厚厚的技术神作给读薄，提炼出其中关于批处理最精华的底层逻辑。
[S01] 其实，当我们沉浸在online system的这种呃及时反馈中时，往往会忽略一个基本事实，就是构建这些智能体验的基础，往往需要极其庞大的数据吞吐量。
[S02] 是的，听起来批处理像个很古老的词汇，甚至有点像上个世纪的计算机术语。
[S01] 哈哈，确实有点。但批处理系统的核心哲学，其实建立在一个非常纯粹的概念之上。那个概念就是输入是绝对不可变的。
[S02] 啊，绝对不可变，也就是数据一旦生成就不允许修改了。
[S01] 没错，它的输入是一堆已经发生过的静止的数据，而它的输出呢被称为派生数据。这种机制其实赋予了系统一种类似时间旅行的超级能力。
[S02] 哇，时间旅行这个说法很有意思。其实这种机制对开发人员的心理状态影响太大了。你想象一下，呃，假设我现在在处理online 系统的实时数据库，手一抖写了个BUG。
[S01] 那线上环境可是会出大事故的。
[S02] 对呀，那些错误的数据会直接覆盖掉真实的用户数据，那种灾难是不可逆的。
[S01] 但在B处理的世界里，情况就完全不同了。
[S02] 因为原始输入数据永远安安静静地躺在那里，绝对不会被修改。
[S01] 没错，这就意味着极度的容错性。如果我发现输出的结果不对啊，或者代码有漏洞，我只需要把错误的那批输出文件整个删掉，然后回滚代码，对着原封不动的输入数据再跑一次就行了。
[S02] 就是这么简单粗暴。这种容忍人为失误的机制，让工程师不再需要战战兢兢的，其实极大地加速了敏捷开发的试错过程。
[S01] 确实剥离了对破坏底层数据的恐惧，大家胆子都变大了。不过那个要真正理解今天这些横跨成千上万台服务器的云计算框架，我们好像得把时钟拨回几十年前。
[S02] 是的，去看看最原始的批处理逻辑。这些精妙的思想其实早就深深烙印在UNIX的命令行里了。
[S01] 每次翻看UNIX的历史，我都觉得这群祖师爷简直是极简主义的大师。资料里给出了一个极其优雅的例子，你听听看啊。假设你手里有一份几个GB大小的网站访问日志。
[S02] 嗯，这是在今天算是很小的数据，但在当时可不小。
[S01] 对，然后你需要从中找出访问量最高的五个网页。如果让一个呃习惯写Python的人来做，他大概率会写个循环，建一个内存内存字典，把每个网页的出现次数一点点累加起来，对吧？
[S02] 这是最直觉的编程思路。
[S01] 但是在UNIX的世界里，处理这种几十GB的数据，竟然只需要一行短短的命令串联。
[S02] 没错，这条流水线通常是这样的。呃，首先用OAK命令提取出每一行日志里的网页URL。
[S01] 嗯哼。
[S02] 紧接着把这些URL输送给SORT命令，让所有相同的URL在物理上紧紧挨在一起。
[S01] 就是把长得一样的全排到一块去。
[S02] 对，随后呢交给UNIC C它会扫描这些相邻的记录，直接统计出它们连续出现的次数。
[S01] 哇，这一步很关键。
[S02] 到了这一步，我们再用一次SORT,不过这次是按照统计出的数字大小进行倒序排列。
[S01] 最后把结果交给HEAD,只需截取最上面的五行，整个过程可以说是行云流水。
[S02] 真的非常丝滑。我特别喜欢把这种UNIX管道，就是那种管线操作，比作一条厨房流水线。
[S01] 厨房流水线，这个比喻怎么说？就是呃，ARC就是那个负责切菜的帮厨，他把切好的土豆丝完全不落地，直接递给下一道负责翻炒的工序，炒完又直接递给负责摆盘的HAT.
[S02] 哈哈，中间不需要弄脏任何多余的盘子去暂存数据。
[S01] 没错，但是这里有一个绕不过去的物理限制。Unix这种极简流水线，在处理小数据的时候简直完美无缺。可如果我的食材啊，也就是数据集大到了五十个GB,而我这台笔记本电脑的内存只有十六个GB呢。
[S02] 那厨房的案板可就放不下这么多菜了。
[S01] 是啊，刚才那种试图把数据全塞进内存递减里去统计的方法，绝对会当场崩溃的。
[S02] 确实，这就触及了批处理系统在单机时代的一项核心绝技了。就是当数据量远超内存上限时，如何利用磁盘来完成任务？
[S01] 呃，具体是怎么做的呢？
[S02] 当工作集小于内存时，内存里的哈希散聊表确实是查找和统计的最快方式。可一旦内存告急，操作系统的SORT命令就会启动一种极为聪明的机制，叫做磁盘归并排序。
[S01] 等等，它是怎么做到不把内存撑爆的？五十个GB数据怎么塞进十六个GB的内存呢？
[S02] 它会化整为零啊，既然一次性吞不下五十个GB,它就先取读，呃，刚好能塞满剩余内存的一小块数据，在内存中飞速排好序。
[S01] 啊，先排好一小部分。
[S02] 对，然后将这块有序的数据作为一个独立的段文件写入磁盘，接着清空内存，取读下一块，继续排序写入。
[S01] 我懂了，最终磁盘上就会生成许多个小型的有序文件。
[S02] 是的，最关键的一步在于归并系统，只需要同时打开这些小文件，依次比较它们当前的最小元素，就能像拉链一样，把它们平滑的合并成一个巨大的、完全有序的最终文件。
[S01] 像拉链一样咬合在一起，这个设计太精妙了。
[S02] 而且这种机制极其契合传统机械磁盘的物理特性。因为磁盘最擅长的就是连续的顺序读写，最害怕的是随机寻找。通过这种方式，单机也能撬动比自身内存大十倍、百倍的数据。
[S01] 这简直就是蚂蚁搬家嘛，只要磁盘空间足够，慢慢矫正能矫完，但这又引申出了另一个维度的挑战。
[S02] 规模膨胀的挑战。
[S01] 对啊，单机的刀工再好，磁盘再大，终归是有物理极限的。当我们面对当今互联网动辄几十上百PB的海量数据时，再高端的单台服务器也无能为力啊。
[S02] 没错，这时候我们的厨房流水线必须扩张成一座拥有几万台机器的巨型城市工厂了。
[S01] 那如果这几万台机器共同组成了一个超大号的分布式操作系统，他们是怎么共享同一个硬盘的呢？
[S02] 呃，他们并不共享一块物理硬盘，而是依靠分布式文件系统，就是大家熟悉的DFS.比如最经典的HDFS.
[S01] 哦，HDFS这个词做大数据的肯定天天听。
[S02] 是的，为了在成千上万个节点间管理PB级别的文件，HDFS在设计上做了一个非常硬核的取舍，那就是极大地拉高了数据块的基础体积。
[S01] 数据块的体积有多大？
[S02] 你个人电脑里的LINUX文件系统，通常会把文件切成四KB大小的小块，但在HDFS中，一个默认的块大小呃，通常是一百二十八枚。
[S01] 哇，一百二十八枚对比四KB,这差距成千上万倍了，为什么要放这么大？底层逻辑是什么？
[S02] 核心瓶颈其实在于原数据的管理。你想象一下，如果一个PB级的数据湖依然用四KB去切块，系统就会产生数以千亿的块，对吧？
[S01] 对，那所以那目录得有多大？
[S02] 就是这个问题，那个负责记录哪个块存放在哪台机器上的中央管理节点，它的内存会瞬间被这些海量的索引数据彻底压垮。
[S01] 嗯，懂了，所以通过将块放大到一百二十八枚甚至更大，原数据的数量就直线下降了，管理节点才得以幸存。
[S02] 没错，同时呢在读取时，磁头寻找数据位置的开销占比也被极大地压缩了，可以说是摸蛤蟆一抓一大把。
[S01] 降低管理成本非常有道理。不过资料里也强调，近年来，传统的DFS正在被像阿玛宗S三这样的对象存储所取代。这本质上是把计算层和存储层完全剥离了吧。
[S02] 是的，这也是现在的趋势。
[S01] 当在看这段资料的时候，我发现了一个极度反直觉的细节。那个你等一下，所以我平时在S三的可视化界面里，一层一层点击那些看起来井然有序的文件夹时，
[S02] 嗯。
[S01] 系统其实是在对我进行视觉欺骗，那里根本不存在真实的文件夹结构。
[S02] 哈哈，你发现了这可能是向云原生存储转型时给人最大的认知颠覆了。
[S01] 这太难以置信了。
[S02] 在S三这种纯粹的对象存储底层，绝对没有你在个人电脑里看到的那种树状目录结构，里面只有极其扁平的海量的对象。
[S01] 那我看到的那些路径是怎么回事？比如二零二六零八零一DATA点CSV这样的。
[S02] 那个路径里的斜杠其实不代表任何层级。那个斜杠仅仅是这个长字符串名字的一部分。在对象存储里，它被称作前缀。
[S01] 哇，这彻底改变了我对删除和重命名操作的理解。也就是说，如果我以为我删除了二零二六这个空文件，实际上系统里根本没有这个操作。
[S02] 完全准确，因为文件从未存在过。
[S01] 那个如果我要把一个包含了十万个文件的所谓文件夹重命名呢？
[S02] 呃，系统在底层其实没法像在电脑上那样秒改一个目录名，它必须把这十万个对象在这全新的长字符串名字逐一复制一遍，然后再把旧名字的对象全部销毁。
[S01] 我的天呐，这太奇妙了。用一维的长字符串，硬生生模拟出了三维的树状结构。
[S02] 这就是云端存储为了无限扩展做出的妥协和创新。
[S01] 好，那现在我们有了可以无限扩展的超级仓库了。但在一个拥有几万台机器的巨型工厂里，必定需要一个极其铁腕且聪明的厂长来分配任务吧。
[S02] 没错，这就是YARN或者KUBERNIS这类资源调度器登场的地方了。
[S01] 分配几万台机器的任务，听起来就不容易。
[S02] 在数学领域，这属于典型的NP Hard问题，也就是极度困难的问题。
[S01] 怎么个困难法？
[S02] 具体来说，当你有数以万计的不同大小、不同优先级的任务，等待塞进几万台资源各异的SERVER中时，可能的组合方式啊比宇宙中的原子数量还要多。
[S01] 哇，那调度器怎么可能穷取出那个最完美的分配方案？那得算到猴年马月去吧。
[S02] 算几千年的不够，所以它必须在极短的时间内使用启发式算法，在效率与公平之间做出权衡。
[S01] 比如呢？
[S02] 比如是冒着让小任务全部饿死的风险，强行腾出一百个节点给一个巨型任务，还是见缝插针的，先把小任务塞进去，这是调度器每秒钟都在做的抉择。
[S01] 懂了，并且呃为了降低这头庞大系统的运行成本呢，各大公司还极其喜欢使用一种叫抢占式实例的云服务器，对吧？
[S02] 对SPOT INSTANCES这种服务器价格极低，能省很多钱。
[S01] 但问题是，云厂商随时有可能毫无预警地拔掉它的电源，把它收回啊，这听起来简直像是在火山口上建工厂。
[S02] 哈哈哈哈，确实很刺激。
[S01] 那万一某个节点在处理一个长达五小时的作业时，突然被强制关机了，整个大作业难道都要全盘推翻重来吗？
[S02] 如果是那样的话，批处理系统就彻底失去了可用性了。现代调度器的精妙之处就在于任务级别的细密度容错。
[S01] 怎么个细密度法？
[S02] 一个耗时五小时的大作业，实际上早就被切分成了十万个微小的独立任务。如果某一台抢占式实例被无情杀掉，
[S01] 也就是被拔电源了。
[S02] 对，调度器只会把那个机器上正在跑的失败的那一两个微小任务，重新分配给网络中其他健康的节点去重试，整体的作业进度几乎是不受影响的。
[S01] 哇，这就展现了系统极强的韧性了。好，现在超级仓库有了，铁腕厂长也安排妥当。接下来的重头戏就是具体怎么在这条分布式的流水线上加工数据。
[S02] 提到这个就不得不聊聊GOOGLE当年提出了如雷而贯的MAP REDUCE了。
[S01] 是的，大数据时代的开山鼻祖。
[S02] MAP REDUCE伟大之处在于它将极其复杂的分布式计算抽现成的两个深受函数式编程启发的简单动作。
[S01] 哪两个动作？
[S02] MAP阶段负责并行地从原始数据中提取出键值对，而REDUCE阶段呃，负责将相同键的数据聚合在一起。
[S01] 听起来很干净利落啊。
[S02] 概念上是很优雅，但在今天看来，它有一个致命的性能瓶颈，那就是它对磁盘IO的极度依赖。
[S01] 我看到资料里指出，上游的MAP任务，如果不把所有的中间计算结果老老实实地全部写到磁盘上，下游的REDUCE任务就绝对没法开工。
[S02] 完全没法开工。
[S01] 这就像工厂里前一道切菜工序，必须把所有的菜切完，然后全部装箱放进冷库，下一道炒菜工序才能去冷库提货，开火也太拖沓了吧。
[S02] 哈哈，确实很拖沓，但我们要理解这种设计的历史局限嘛。
[S01] 哦，都是有什么局限？
[S02] 在二零零四年左右的硬件环境下，GOOGLE使用的大多数便宜而且极易损坏的普通商业电脑节点崩溃，简直是家常便饭。
[S01] 所以不得不频繁存档。
[S02] 没错，MAP REDUCE疯狂地将中间状态写入磁盘，其实是为了保命。只有把数据硬生生地写到物理磁盘上，一旦机器宕机，其他机器才能接手这部分进度。
[S01] 原来如此，是被逼出来的。
[S02] 对，而在MAP阶段和REDUCE阶段之间，其实隐藏着分布式批处理真正的心脏搏动。混洗也就是SHUFFLE.
[S01] 诶，这里我必须打断一下，关于混洗或者说SHUFFLE这个词，我觉得它简直是计算机科学里呃最容易让人产生误解的术语之一了。
[S02] 怎么说？
[S01] 你想啊，SHUFFLE的英文原意是洗牌，听起来就像是把数据丢进滚筒洗衣机里，随机打乱一样。
[S02] 哈哈，字面上确实是这个意思。
[S01] 但这完全背离了它的本质，这根本不是洗牌，这完全就是一个超大型极度严密的邮政分拣中心。
[S02] 哇，这个比喻非常精准。按照这个邮政逻辑推演下去，每一条数据就是一封信，而数据的KEY就是邮政编码。
[S01] 对，无论这封信是从全国几万个邮筒，呃，也就是MAP节点中的哪一个被投递进来的，只要它的邮政编码一致，
[S02] 它就必须且绝对没有任何随机性的被极其精准的路由并打包，最终送进同一个邮局的同一个分拣筐里。
[S01] 也就是指定的REDUCE的节点。
[S02] 完全正确。正是这种极度确定的分发机制，让我们能把分布在几万台机器上的属于同一个用户的十年浏览记录，完美的汇聚到一个节点上进行分析。
[S01] 太厉害了，所以真不该叫它混洗。
[S02] 是的，不过正如我们前面探讨的，MAP REDUCE那种走一步就往磁盘里存一次档的模式，在如今内存变得极其廉价，网络极其发达的时代显得过于笨重了。
[S01] 所以大家现在都换工具了。
[S02] 没错，这就催生了SPARK和FLINK这类现代的数据流引擎。
[S01] 他们是怎么跨越磁盘瓶颈的？资料里提到了一个叫有向无环图，也就是DAG的东西。
[S02] 就纵览全局的执行蓝图。
[S01] 全局蓝图。
[S02] 以前的MAP REDUCE是走一步看一步，而SPARK引擎在拿到你的任务后，会先看这张蓝图，因为它预知了未来所有的步骤，它就能极其聪明地将多个连续的操作融合在一次循环里完成。
[S01] 也就是说，不需要每一步都存盘了。
[S02] 对，只要数据流向允许，它会尽大努力把中间状态保留在内存里，直接在节点之间通过网络飞速传递，让开了沉重的磁盘读写，整体速度自然获得了指数级的提升。
[S01] 底层的演进确实令人叹为观止。但是呃现实世界中其实存在一个体验鸿沟。
[S02] 体验鸿沟。
[S01] 你想啊，如果一家公司每天都要求业务分析师或者数据科学家去手写那种DAG蓝图，或者编写底层的加瓦代码，那这套系统永远无法普及，大家都疯了。
[S02] 那是肯定的。计算引擎再强大，也必须进化出一种让人类大脑感到舒适的交互语言。
[S01] 所以谁成了最终的赢家？
[S02] 毫不意外，结构化查询语言，也就是SQL最终统一了这片战场，成为了批处理领域的通用语。
[S01] SQL确实是老少皆宜。
[S02] 现代的批处理引擎在内部嵌入了极其强大的代价优化器。你只需要用SQL表达我想要什么，结果优化器会自动评估各种执行路径的代价。
[S01] 它连怎么执行最优都能自己想出来。
[S02] 是的，甚至自动重排你关联多张表的中印顺序，最终把你的意图翻译成那张复杂的DAG蓝图。
[S01] 但这引发了我一个很深的疑惑。
[S02] 你说。
[S01] 既然像SNOWFLAKE这样的现在云数据仓库不仅支持标准的SQL,而且并发能力极强。而我们今天聊的SPARK这种批处理系统也全面拥榜了SQL.
[S02] 对。
[S01] 那它们俩在业务层面上不就变成同一个东西了吗？数据湖仓就是LAKEHOUSE的概念，也在模糊这两者的边界。我们为什么还要在两套系统里纠结呢？为什么不直接把所有东西都塞进数据仓库？
[S02] 这是一个非常核心的架构抉择。虽然接口都是SQL,但底层的能力侧重可是截然不同的。
[S01] 嗯，主要区别在哪儿？
[S02] 首先是海量计算的经济性。当你要扫描几十PB的历史数据时，原数据仓库的计算计费可能会让公司瞬间破产。
[S01] 这么贵啊。
[S02] 是的，而基于廉价储存和计算节点分离的批处理系统成本优势极大。更关键的一点在于数据形态。
[S01] 数据形态？
[S02] 数据仓库是为高度结构化的表格数据而生的。但如果你面对的是几千万张图片，海量的音频，或者是几十亿篇参差不齐的网页文档，数据仓库就收手无策了。
[S01] 啊，这就完美切入了当前最火热的AI和大语言模型领域了。
[S02] 没错。
[S01] 如果没有批处理，那些动辄千亿参数的大模型，根本连训练的数据口粮都吃不上。
[S02] 就是这样，在把文本喂给大模型进行训练之前，你需要进行浩如烟海的预处理工作。比如清洗低质量的网页识别语言分词转化为向量表示。
[S01] 这些都是非结构化数据。
[S02] 对，比如OPENAI在训练大模型时，就大量使用了像RAY这样的现代分布式框架。这类框架甚至为了迎合数据科学家的习惯，引入了分布式的DATAFRAMES.
[S01] DATAFRAMES就是PANDAS里的那个。
[S02] 没错，就是把单机PANDAS的体验无缝放大到了一万台机器上。科学家只需要调用熟悉的函数，底层的脏活累活全部由批处理框架自动调度。
[S01] 哇，这就太舒服了。好，那么当我们历经千辛万苦，通过强大的引擎和AI框架，练出了一份极其完美的数据。比如，一份包扛了千万级用户的绝对精准的商品推荐列表。现在我们要上态了，
[S02] 到了最关键的一步。
[S01] 如果这个时候某个工程师脑子一热，直接在SPARK作业的最后一行写个代码，把这几千万条推荐数据啪的一下，并发写入线上，正在服务用户的生产造户剧里会发生什么？
[S02] 呃，它将亲手制造一场史诗级的灾难。
[S01] 哈哈灾难。
[S02] 绝对的。批处理系统为了高吞吐量，同时会有几百上千个任务在疯狂运转。如果让它们直接向线上的生产造户剧猛烈写入，这种瞬时的超高并发，本质上
[S01] 本质上和黑客发起的DDOS攻击毫无区别吧。
[S02] 一模一样。
[S01] 换句话说，批处理巨大的吞吐量，就像一把全功率开启的消防高压水枪，而线上数据库只是一株脆弱的小盆栽。你直接拿水枪去浇花，盆栽当场就粉碎了。
[S02] 这个比喻非常贴切。并且除了压垮数据库，这种做法还致命地破坏了我们一开始提到的批处理的纯粹性。
[S01] 也就是全有或全无。
[S02] 对，如果这个写入任务执行到百分之五十的时候崩溃了，已经写进生产数据库的那一半数据就成了外部可见的脏数据。由于这些副作用已经产生，你极难将它们回滚清理。
[S01] 那重新跑一遍任务呢？
[S02] 重新跑一遍，甚至可能导致推荐列表出现大量重复，用户体验极其糟糕。
[S01] 所以为了保护我们的小盆栽，同时保证数据的原子性，业界正确的解法到底是什么？
[S02] 第一种常见的解法是引入流处理系统，比如KAF卡作为缓冲减震器。
[S01] 是那么缓冲法。
[S02] 批处理引擎不直接找数据库，而是把这几千万条数据倾泻到卡夫卡这条急速的高速公路里。然后线上的生产系统再根据自身能承受的频率，平滑地从卡夫卡中拉取数据。
[S01] 嗯，就像在消防水枪和小盆栽之间接了一个巨大的缓冲水箱，让狂暴的水流变成涓涓细流。资料里好像还提到了另一种更干脆的做法。
[S02] 是的，第二种做法是彻底的离线构建。我们不再让数据库去一条条插入数据，而是直接在批处理的离线环境里，按照数据库底层的物理存储格式，把数据全部打包成不可变的静态文件。
[S01] 比如常见的SST文件。
[S02] 没错，这些SST文件本质上就是已经排好序的数据块。构建完成后，只需将这些文件传送到数据库服务器上，发送一条极轻量的挂载命令。
[S01] 然后呢？
[S02] 数据库只需将新文件连接上去，就可以瞬间完成千万级新老数据的原子切换。
[S01] 哇，太精妙了。这就像餐厅后厨，不是端着一口大铁锅，跑到客人的餐桌上去炒菜，而是在后厨把菜品连盘子一起精心装盘，盖上盖子，最后只需一秒完美的呈现在客人面前。
[S02] 这个形容太到位了。
[S01] 五、今天我们真的跨越了极其广阔的版图。从几十年前UNIX命令行里极简的ARC和SORT到跨越数万台机器，通过DIG和内存计算狂飙的数据流引擎，再到支撑起当今最前沿AI大模型数据清洗的隐形基石。
[S02] 批处理的技术演进确实波澜壮阔。
[S01] 是啊，批处理这项看似缺乏及时快感的技术，依靠着输入不可变的哲学，给了我们在数据洪流中无限试错从容纠偏的底气。
[S02] 这也是它在当今依然不可替代的原因。
[S01] 不过在今天这期深度解析的尾声，呃，我想给你，也就是正在收听的你留一个稍微有些烧脑的思考题。
[S02] 哦，什么思考题？
[S01] 我们今天探讨的所有批处理架构，它们发挥威力的前提都在于输入的数据是有限的，英文叫BUNDRED,它必须有一个明确的起点和终点，我们才能计算出一个静态的结果。
[S02] 没错，这是批处理的定义。
[S01] 但是如果你把时间轴拉得无限长，把目光投向现实世界。我是说现实中这个世界上真的存在绝对有限的数据吗？只要人类还在活动，系统还在运转，数据流其实就是永无止境的。
[S02] 切实数据永远在产生。
[S01] 所以试想一下，如果我们把原本每天晚上跑一次的批处理任务，通过极其强大的算力压缩到每分钟跑一次，每秒钟跑一次，甚至每一毫秒跑一次。
[S02] 那样的话。
[S01] 那么，批处理和实时流处理之间的那道技术鸿沟，是不是在极度的时间压缩下就彻底消失了？
[S02] 想象一下，在不久的将来，如果底层系统能够用同一套优雅的代码，同一个统一的引擎，既能从容不迫地回溯过去十年的浩瀚历史，又能极其敏锐地响应当下一毫秒的现实波动。
[S01] 那将是数据处理的终极形态了。
[S02] 那会是一个怎样不可思议的数字世界。
[S01] 非常感谢你在这个深度的技术世界中投入宝贵的时间与我们一同探索。
[S02] 期待下次再见。
[S01] 期待下一次的深度探讨，我们再见。